calais prévu d'aller voir le président
quoi alors pas du tout l'histoire est un
peu folle parce que ce matin justin
télétravail chez moi chez mes parents
ouais et là j'apprends que macron le
président m'a convient bien aux arbres
et donc du coup à la base j'y vais pour
pour lui poser une question mais qui n'a
rien à voir avec ça au début honnêtement
je suis étudiant messieurs entrepreneurs
développe une start up qui s'appelle
stud arc pour aider les artistes
étudiants à vendre leurs oeuvres et à
lutter contre la précarité accor est en
fait à la base vous lui posez une
question presse propos là par rapport à
mon projet et c est en fait moi je suis
hyper fan de l'émission faut savoir donc
je regarde tout le temps tous les débats
qui sera et j'étais assez déçu qu'ils ne
viennent pas après bon il ya un emploi
du temps c'est assez chargé et voilà
j'ai dû lui demander directement en fait
au moment glissé à la main c'est la
première question qui m'est venue c'est
pourquoi nous voir si on va regarder sa
montre
en fait mais je comprends pas pourquoi
nous mettons toutes les émissions
populaires comme tu ferais mon poste
notamment face à va j'aimerais bien vous
y voir et les plupart des jeunes
français sont là dessus donc vraiment
pense que c'est intéressant les
nouvelles bien vous défendre mais on
attend que vous veniez aussi montrer nos
belles idées pour la france mais
j'essaie de montrer partout en fait la
plus
je vais en faire j'en fais trop mal
comme vous savez
il sera lundi sur france 5 apparemment
oui eh bah déjà bravo abidal ce qui
n'est pas journaliste mais il a posé la
question que tous les journalistes
devraient poser en ce moment et que
personne ne pose et il a posé donc c'est
bien et ensuite sur non plus massif et
une basse et une vraie question parce
que c'est marine le pen a répondu à ça
il ya un vrai débat autour de ça et
ensuite je trouve qu emmanuel macron sur
sa réponse il fait que de la forme et
aucun fond il est très sympathique et
vous il vous prend le temps de vous
répondre ça le rend sympathique mais sur
le fond il répond rien il dit pourquoi
vous ne venez pas dans des ripostes
d'indications ai dit pourquoi vous ne
venez pas dans des émissions populaires
dit ah vous fait la pub pour cyril
hanouna oui je fais de la pub il pose
une vraie question est il dit non j'ai
pas le temps c'est pas vrai
serveur ce moment
si rio il m'a dit je fais plein
d'émissions j'ai pas le temps mais qui
trouve le temps de faire mcphail carlito
et hugo décrypte
le faire et je pense qu'il peut trouver
le temps de faire face à bah non j'ai
rien qui donne une vraie réponse c'est
qu'il fasse pas que de la forme comme ça
même si là il ne tient pas debout répond
bilal qu'alléchant pense qu'ils auraient
tout intérêt aussi à faire une émission
comme ça ça va c'est ce que je lui
disais un petit peu au début c'est une
mission qui est hyper regarder que ce
soit auprès des jeunes ne prennent pas
un public hyper large donc moi je trouve
ça dommage encore une fois quand on voit
qu au second poteau et à l'extrême
droite qui viennent pas justement de
défendre ses idées contre l'extrême
droite est à voir lui sont propres son
propre parcours son propre bilan et
justement la possibilité d'avoir dit
citoyen qui va nous poser des vraies
questions sur leur quotidien j'aurais
trouvé ça hyper intéressant mais je le
vois tu heureux de levante oui assez
heureux oui oui même s'il était supposé
guillaume très drôle très gentil très
sympa donc oui très heureux oui alors
oui je trouve que guillaume la d'élire
un peu parce qu'il se rend pas compte de
l'énormité de la réponse le président
arrive il est face à un jeune comme ça
il pourrait tout à fait fuir il dit avec
humour ou fait de la pub pour serrer la
nouba etc il répond il dit je vais
essayer d'en faire guillaume attend
quand même il bouge il répond
indirectement un jeune là tu peux pas
dire qui fuit sur le débat de voix c'est
quoi sa réponse pourquoi vous ne venez
pas d'en face à bastia vous faites de la
pub pour signer le meneur oui je vais
essayer d'en faire d'accord mais
j'essaie acompte président de la
république qui répond un jeune comme ça
de presque d'égal à égal je fais pas du
tout politique et tu trouves qui fait de
la langue de bois pas sur la secte est
d'ailleurs en santé beaucoup de
sympathie pour cyril hahn bin oui quand
ils vous axez pas qui c'est mais oui non
mais alors et un joli et c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que voilà après je vous dis
un truc c'est que ils ont calé
énormément de choses sont ses
conseillers qui ont calé énormément
démission sur ses quinze jours
ils n'avaient pas prévu de faire une
émission avec moi parce qu'en plus nous
voilà on attendait voilà je vous l'avais
dit on a attendu le vendredi juste avant
le le premier tour pour voir et on
appelait on appelait tout ce qui était
susceptible d'aller au deuxième poteau
pour voir s'ils pouvaient faire une
émission avec nous donc là le truc c'est
que ils sont en train de voir s'ils
peuvent peut-être faire un truc voilà
avec nous de calais un truc voilà entre
je crois que sur la semaine qui arrive
ou la semaine puisque après ce sera fini
forcément moi je vais direct ainsi rien
ah c'est vrai que c'est un truc que je
suis pro mais là je t'inviterai
managériale invitera alors je sais pas
sur quelle forme on va le faire je sais
pas si on va le faire mais en tout cas
voilà c'est vrai que c'était pas prévu
dans l'agenda
l'info qu'on a c'est pas débat il
n'était même pas au courant lui pour
tout va c'est ça ouais c'est quand même
grave il n'était pas au courant
franchement puisque j'ai posé la
question évidemment à qui de droit
n'était pas au courant donc l'agenda
était déjà booké puisqu'on va c'est
quand même extrêmement sérieux ces cinq
ans de l'avis des français mais bon
voilà sur l'avait prévenu qu'ils
auraient intégré dans l'agenda il aurait
fait ce que d'abord il connaît très bien
cyrille et l'apprécient et déjà cyril
avait interviewé l'époque pour rapper
avant les deux tours oui au premier tour
il ya sept ans le premier de tous y
voilà ok pas de problème oui clément
marche parce que c'est quand même une
erreur stratégique des manuels macron de
refuser de venir d'en face à bah parce
que il ne cible que des émissions qui
sont regardés par des personnes âgées
seules émissions déjà son public qui a
déjà voilà il faut savoir que justement
les jeunes au premier tour en beauté à
34% pour jean luc mélenchon les jeunes
regardent face à baba donc je pense
qu'il devrait venir chercher ces jeunes
là et il ne va pas les voir il sera par
exemple dans sept à huit dimanche les
jeunes ne regarde pas cette a8 et les
jeunes il faut vraiment qu'ils aillent
le chercher dans des émissions où il n'a
pas l'habitude d'aller moi c'est vrai
que j'ai demandé à ma fille qui a 18 ans
qui est primo votants t elle entré en
politique grâce à face à bah c'est vrai
elle a écouté tous les débats là puisse
faire son idée trouver des candidats
plus convaincant moins convaincant et
aujourd'hui que c'est vrai qu'elle me
demande mais je comprends pas la raison
même purement opportuniste de la part de
maquereaux à ne pas accepter cette
émission alors moi je vous demande est
ce que vous pensez que le fait que vous
avez dit que c'était des citoyens
engagés qui avait parcouru le
quinquennat pour lui et donc pour marine
le pen le même panel de citoyens c'est
ça est ce que finalement ça crée un
déséquilibre dans ses équipes qu'ils ont
imaginé qui à mon avis une erreur mois
avant tout petit niveau du fait que lui
était donc avec un bilan contrairement à
marine le pen et comment que ça
déséquilibre est malgré tout le process
dire que lui la lettre face à un bilan
et elle face à un programme et est ce
que blanc on sait que cela pouvait
biaiser le programme en lui même je
pense que je pense que ça ce n'est même
pas arrivé depuis le le principe
inception dans le bernard
bernard et moi ça il n'a pas eu le
concept de l'émission dans du tout comme
vous le décrivez labécédois il a il n'a
pas eu les détails de l'émission je
pense voilà et jusque là revoilà à nice
on y trouve bien qu'il a peur de rien un
peu quand ils vont au contact des gens
vous avez bien lu hier on l'a dit lénine
donne ordre à son service de sécurité de
ne surtout pas baisser ses taux mais
l'ancien
séquence mais du côté de bilel parce que
c'est vrai qu'à eu plein de voile a eu
plein de caméras dessus il a été une
brèche
au débat
allons-y voir si la clarification sur le
terrain et nous on aime bien vous
défendre mais on aimerait bien vous
veniez aussi montrer vos bonnes idées
pour la france mais
prendre la mauvaise vidéos qui sont nuls
voilà j'en ai plein mon nom mais encore
une fois le choc que le président était
très cordiales avec moi justement je
vais poser une question qui est un peu
délicate comme disait guillaume toi tu
es fan du président je dirais pas que je
suis fan d'accord encore une fois je dis
que je trouve qu'il a des belles idées
par rapport à marine le pen ça je le
maintiens mais je dirais pas que suis
fan je pas du tout encartés et c'est là
qu'après je le mans pacs un candidat que
je trouve qu'il a des idées
intéressantes notamment quand on voit
qu'il est au second tour face à marine
le pen moi en tant que jeunes et en tant
que papa par rapport à mes convictions
il faut que ces candidats qui me
représente le plus au second tour
certainement très saddam à raymond c'est
un mois cette séquence que c'est vrai
que moi j'ai bien aimé pour une fois
j'ai vu un président qui tient sultan
pas qui est pas méchant qui dit pas
pensé avec vos têtes cette marche est
votre tête ou je ne sais pas quoi ils
discutent le dialogue et bien il sourit
les projets de répondre contrairement à
ce que dit guillaume il est obligé de
répondre oui je vais y aller parce qu'il
ya un jeune qui lui a dit ça et ne pas
venir je préfère qu'ils disent comme ça
je vais voir je vais le j'ai le temps
après sur ce que dit bernard sur
l'agenda c'est lui qui décide l'agenda
ci veut virer un truc pour mathieu noté
mission c'est lui qui décide c'est le
maître des horloges s'appelle un
président de la république il a décidé
pour nous il a décidé pour notre santé
l'a dit il a mis plein de trucs en place
pour nous pour nous protéger il peut dit
peu déclare il est bon on peut pas tout
gérer mais c'est quand même le président
et je rejoins clément sur ce qu'a dit
clément très intelligent ce qu'a dit
clément les les anciens et les a déjà
les personnes âgées les gens qui les a
déjà parce qu'il a passé les jeunes il
faut qu'ils se méfient qui ont voté pour
mélenchon qui se méfie dans sa stratégie
je sais ce que j'ai dit on et valérie
pécresse mais vote de valérie pécresse
les votes dupont aignan les votes de
d'eric zemmour les votes de mélenchon il
faut qu'il se méfie de toute cette
mayonnaise c'est vrai que les gens en
ont eu ras-le-bol de sa politique de
cinq ans et qui vont mettre le bulletin
et ça après ce sera trop tard pour dire
maintenant je veux bien me faire des
trucs ce sera trop tard donc c'est fait
c'est fait lorsque je vous ai dit j'ai
bien aimé la séquence mobylette qui vous
diraient oui je suis assez d'accord avec
raymond est en fait tout ce que je
trouve de match et que notamment au
premier tour mais emmanuel macron
entendu son bilan son bilan pardon mais
uniquement à travers ses opposants c'est
à dire je n'ai pas fait si pour les
jeunes les apl et c est moi je trouvais
ça intéressant qui viennent dans une
émission hyper hyper populaire comme
cette comme la tienne de cyril pour
justement défendre son programme d'hier
bas certes il ya des choses que j'ai pas
bien fait et encore une fois je dis pas
que macro à tout bien fait mais par
exemple moi j'avais un job étudiant
pendant la période co-lead je les ai
perdus et j'étais bien
bien très heureux d'avoir un repas 1
euros le midi et le soir il ya des
choses qui n'ont pas été bien fait je
suis d'accord mais des choses qui ont
été faites et qui ont été je trouve
réussit donc j'aurais bien aimé qu'il
vienne sur un plateau échanger avec des
personnes comme ça pour défendre ses
idées mais gilles après on voit que les
deux candidats ils s'ajustent alors ils
ont un programme et il s'ajuste en
fonction des derniers sondages en
fonction de ce qui se passe et là il ya
quand même une montée des jeunes les
jeunes certains jeunes ont l'impression
entre guillemets qu'on leur a volé le
premier tour effectivement ils ont voté
pour mélenchon on voit dans les
universités est passé devant la sorbonne
aujourd'hui la grande université paris
c'était hyper chaud et dans les slogans
c'était non à marine le pen mais non à
maquereau aussi donc le président il
peut très bien dans les prochains jours
se dire effectivement l'électorat jeune
et très important fondamentale et ça
peut le décider en fait tout a bougé
rien est écrit mais il valoir 40% pardon
j'ai les 40% des jeunes n'ont pas voté
absolument 40% c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
en train la tradition pas motivé c'est
ça qui s'était il faut aller chercher la
charge des réservoirs de gasoil à 40%
des jeunes n'ont pas voté ils n'auront
peut-être pas contrairement à des gens
qui sont convaincus qu'on a eu et et
votez pour mélenchon j'ai dit à l'heure
pour tous les autres candidats et y
retourneront voter au deuxième tour ça
l'est peut-être savez peut-être là sans
erreur de dire je vais pas besoin des
jeunes des 40% n'y a jamais dit ça fout
oui mais il n'a jamais dit ça tous les
présidents en fait ils ont eu leur
galère tous les présidents chirac il a
eu ces guerres dans le monde sarkozy la
crise en 2008 hollande il a eu ces
attentats et lui il a eu un truc qui est
tombée sur la gueule qu'on ne pouvait
pas prévoir c'est le co vite et l'autre
ils ont tous su et après à sa crise et
je règle et les autres présents ils ont
pas insulter les français comme lui
insulté les français c'est ça qu'il faut
qu'ils réparent souviendra quand ils
n'étaient pas si oui ça reconnaît
sans
réponse mac avec les gens et d'ailleurs
les dégâts matériels dit pas que c'était
bien je te dire les présidents ou leurs
galères mais là maintenant ce qu'il faut
qu'il aille chercher c'est d'arrêter de
faire croire qu'ils emmerdent les
français c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il était
un vrai raymond tous les présidents pour
la pro a mais vu les précédents au bout
de cinq ans on lit des gages sarko on
dégage hollande on dégage en fait c'est
ça le truc c'est pas il fait pas propre
à maquereau ça la démocratie c'est le
vote bah oui mais donc ses traits de
vote on a gardé chira deux fois par
semaine pas de répit mais c'est marrant
ça que j'ai en tunisie aussi avaient ils
avaient jean marie le pen jean-marie oui
jean marie le pen le père en 2002 c'est
là que je me suis intéressé moi j'ai
entendu des trucs oui on a créé des
monstres sur les plateaux mais les le
pen ça fait vingt ans les gars c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui c'est 2012 2017 et la 2022
donc qu'on dise aujourd'hui on a créé
des zemmour on a créé des machins a créé
des machins non c'est 2022 il était déjà
les le pen donc faut comprendre aussi
les gens qui franchissent pas le pas
mais qui à un moment donné vont en avoir
ras-le-bol qu'on leur dise faut pas
voter le pen faut pas voter le pen faut
pas voter le pen moi j'ai moi je fais
attention à ça à ces gens là qui on a
dit tu verras ça va changer en 2002 on
leur a dit ça va changer hier un cas
changer les gens ils sont encore plus
dans la merde qu'avant en 2010 7 ans a
dit oui mais attention là votre mac rond
ça va changer c'était encore pire il ya
eu les gilet jaune et là on en ressort
encore le même discours oui mais
attention c'est le maintenant tu vas
voir ça va changer son vous méfier de ça
c'est très dangereux c'est très très
dangereux cette connerie